I I do not think that God need like I
don't think human sacrifice is needed to
cure sins. Like you can just ask for
forgiveness and God will forgive you.
She all
that's not true. Now now can we show
her? Yeah. Go ahead. That's not true.
He's going to show you. Allah doesn't
simply forgive you. He he he
demands
atonement. I think you guys have
complicated your religion. Yes. We've
complicated it. Yes. Because that is uh
very complicated. So let let me ask you,
do you believe that it is satanic? It's
a satanic idea that somebody else takes
on the sins of someone else. You believe
that that's satanic and evil? No. No man
could pay for another man's sin. And no
beautiful nobody. No man, nobody
everybody's accountable for their own
sins. There's no such thing as if my
sister said I'm uncomfortable for it.
There's no such thing as that. Everyone
is accountable for their own sin and on
the day of judgment God is going to
judge that individual person based on
their own sins and it has always been
like that from the beginning of so that
doesn't answer my question. Do you
believe that it is evil for someone to
take on the sins of another for God to
put somebody else's sins on another
person? Do you believe that that's evil?
It's not it's not it's not even evil.
It's just it's illogical. It's
illogical. And so this is something that
this is something that God would never
do.
Why would Why would somebody commit a
sin and he would put it on somebody
else? I just I'm just asking. You're
saying God would never do that cuz it's
illogical. It doesn't make sense.
He would not give somebody else somebody
else's sin. Okay. So you just condemned
Allah. Now wait before you go on guys.
He said she said he will not condemn you
because of someone else's sins. She said
it. Heard it. Now watch bis
watch what he's going he's going to give
you a sahi Muslim what are you going to
show Muslim 2767a
Muslim 2767a
s Muslim 2767a
it says Allah's messenger said when it
will be the day of resurrection
Allah will deliver to every Muslim a Jew
or a Christian and say that is your
ransom from hellfire. That's your rescue
from hellfire. So according to Muhammad,
Allah is going to save the Muslims from
hell by giving them a Jew or a Christian
to replace them. What can I have that
hadith please? Shocked. Absolutely you
can have it. Yeah, give me that. I I
would I would have to do my research, my
extensive research on a hadith and see
what it actually means. I know you now
it has to mean something. Okay, the case
this why we told you what's the name of
the hadith? Sah Muslim. So I'm going
tell you where to find it. When you go
to sunna.com, you listening? Yeah. When
you go to sunna.com,
put in 2767A
2767A.
If you're in the comment section on
YouTube, we can give you links or if you
me or him. Now, I'm telling you guys
now, ain't no way in my Quran and Allah
says that people will pick other
people's sex. That's what it says here.
I'm going to give that I have to say the
hadith and I have to understand what it
actually means. Oh, you know, let me let
me do this for you, you know, just for
you. If we could send you links, I'mma
flip the screen so you can see it
yourself. Show her the others, too.
Because we love you and you're our
favorite. How much here? All right.
She loves when you say that. But be
careful. Don't fall in love with the
Christian man. You got to marry Muslim
man. So, look. You see it? Sah Muslim
2767A. You see it? Yeah. All right. So,
it says wait for it. Abu Mus reported
that Allah's messenger said when it will
be the day of resurrection, Allah would
deliver to every Muslim a Jew or a
Christian and say that is your rescue
from hellfire.
Isn't that crazy? You want to show you
want him to get it gets worse. That's
not So, did you register that?
But you got that? Yeah. I'm I'm typing
it up so I can see the what what where
the verse come out from and what it
actually it's right here. It's it's sah.
It has to have a It has to has a reason.
Yeah. The reason is this. The reason is
that I don't think Allah is saying that
he's going to give Oh, yeah. There
there's a reason. There is a reason.
That's not what it's saying. The reason
is the re the reason is because a Muslim
dies sayingahillah
right while the Jews and the Christians
are considered as disbelievers since
they reject Allah and Muhammad. So
because of that the Muslim will be
rescued from hell by Allah placing their
sins upon a Jew or a Christian. Why do
you say that he's placing our sins? I I
got you. That's all you had to ask. I
got you. You didn't. That's all you had
to ask. Watch this. Here's another one.
Abu Ba reported on on the authority of
his father that Allah's apostle said
this. No Muslim would die,
but Allah would admit in hisstead
a Jew or a Christian in hellfire. So
Allah's replacing the Muslim with a Jew
or a Christian. So the Muslim deserves
to go to hell, right? But Allah is going
to replace them with a Jew or a
Christian. Just a picture of that. Now
the other one he's going to show you.
There's another one. Now watch this one
because you say ask about the sins,
right? Watch the sins here. 668. So same
thing. 2767D.
This just remember this is not Quran.
This is not this is
I have to see how how strong this is and
how this is and what about and who was
saying this hadith I have to say who was
saying this hadith why why did they say
this what is Muhammad said it didn't
write this Muhammad Muhammad said it I
would I would I have to do my research
to see if this is a authentic hadith it
is it's sahi Muslim if it's weak or if
it's staying or what Sis, sis, it's sah.
What does sahi mean?
What does sahi mean? Tell me. That's a
that's a person. Sah Muslim. Yeah. Yeah.
Well, Muslim is the person. What does
sahi mean? I don't know. Sure. Sa sahi
means authentic. You have sahi, which is
strong, authentic. You have hassan,
which is good. You have
which is weak. This is sahi Muslim just
like sahi alkari. This is sahi Muslim.
And I'm going to show in the Quran. I'm
going to show in the Quran where it says
that you will suffer
and cause people suffer for your sins.
People do suffer because of other people
sin. We sure
read this. Yep. So look, Sai Muslim
2767D. Don't let don't let nobody try to
tell you that is weak.
It says here there would come
people amongst the Muslims on the day of
resurrection with as heavy sins as a
mountain. You want you looking at this?
I see. I mean so good. So they come, the
Muslims will come on the day of
resurrection with as heavy sins as a
mountain. That's how much sins they
have. And Allah would forgive them and
he would place in theirstead the Jews
and the Christians. That's how Allah
forgives them by replacing them with
Jews and Christians. taking their sins
that are as heavy as a mountain and
replacing them and placing them on the
Jews and the Christians.
Okay, let me see. Okay, so I have found
the explanation.
Okay, in case can I show you some Quran
verses
about what about that you suffer because
of someone else's sins?
I'm I'm afraid I don't have the
knowledge on this. Okay. But I'll give
you the verses for you to examine. I'm
just going to read them for you, right?
Um, no. It's up to you because you said
Quran. He gave you hadith. I want to
give you Quran.
Yes. No.
Yeah. Okay. Here. I'm going to read for
you. 29:12
Quran 29. Surah 29:12-13. Pay attention.
Okay. I'm going to read it for you. You
ready?
You ready?
Yeah. Okay. Chapter 29:12-13. Write it.
And those who disbelieve, say to those
who believe, disbelievers say to those
who believe, follow our way, and we will
verilely bear your sins.
Never will they bear anything of their
sins. Surely they are liars. Now watch
though. And verily they shall bear their
own loads and other loads besides their
own. And verily they shall be questioned
on the day of resurrection about that
which they used to fabricate. Let me
repeat that part. They will bear their
own burdens, loads of sin, and other
loads besides their own. So here it's
saying there'll be people who carry
their own loads of sin and the loads of
sins of others. Why is that? It's from
an article on our website. Now let me
give you another one. You ready? I have
the I have the meaning for the first
verse that you posted about Sah Muslim.
No, you don't because your gold is not
going to help you. Okay, I can I can
give the explanation to you right now.
Who wants to hear it? Go ahead try but
it's not because you know I have to ask
to speak
and you know I have to ask to speak and
and give but you can try. I gave you
Quran. You didn't did you pay attention
to the Quranic verse I gave you or no?
Um I was busy reading. See okay the
Quran just said 29 1213. Here it is. It
says they will carry their own burdens
and the burdens of others their sins. So
here it says there will be people who
carry their own burden of sins and also
the burden of sins of others. Why? Why
are they carrying two loads? Theirs and
someone else's
I don't know. Okay. Can I give you
another one from the Quran?
For the Christians. For the Christians
that was chapter 29 12-13. Are you ready
for the other one or no? From what I
from what I know that if I have
encouraged somebody to sin or I taught
them something that was sinful each time
they do it I will get punishment as
well. That's what I know. But I don't
think that she's saying she's saying
that for what she knows is that it's if
she teaches to do something bad, she'll
be punished for teaching someone to do
something bad. Oh, so that means hold
on. If you cause someone to sin, you
share in their sin.
Meaning that if I teach Oh, so you do
suffer because of someone's sins. If you
have an influence over that, if I'm I'm
saying, listen to what I'm saying. I'm
not saying that if somebody sins, it's
not my responsibility. But if I have
taught them if I have taught them that
sin, okay? And I have So you taught
someone a sin, but they commit sin, not
you. But you still suffer for the sin
they committed, not you. Yes. And also
here here's the next fact. Here's the
next fact. If if I teach someone good
and they have and do if I
and do something good, I would always
Oh, if you teach someone to do good and
he does a good, it benefits you. Yes. So
when Jesus did good, it benefited you.
Oh my god. I'm not talking about Jesus.
Yes. Jesus is your God. Oh my God and
Lord Savior. Guys, did you hear it?
Wait. If I teach someone to do good and
he does the good y then I will be
blessed by the good he so Jesus did good
for us and we benefit and we wow why you
why are you incorporating Jesus my
beloved prophet in this okay so thank
you for proving the Christian god
prophet I can't even read the other
Quran do you want Quran or you just want
to keep talking I want to give you
another Quran verse
my beloved can I give you another
Quranic verse my My poor beloved Jesus.
She cried. Can I give you another
choronic eye? She goes, "My poor beloved
Jesus." Because we had we had him nailed
on the cross. You guys have made my my
my prophet alone. Okay. Can I give you
another Quranic verse on that we will
suffer the sins we committed and the
sins of others? Yes or no? You want it
or no? No, go ahead. Okay. Chapter 16,
guys. Write it down. Chapter 16 22-2. 16
22 to 25. Okay. Here. You said no.
That's not Yes, it is. Okay. Your God is
one God. So as for those who do not
believe in the hereafter, their hearts
are ignorant and they are proud. Truly
Allah knows what they hide and what they
manifest. Surely he does not love the
proud. And when it is said to them,
what is it that your Lord has revealed?
They say stories of the ancients. These
are fables mom is reciting that they now
watch that they may bear their burdens
entirely on the day of resurrection and
also of the burdens of those whom they
led astray without knowledge. Now surely
evil is what they bear. So you're right
if I mislead him and he sins he gets
punished and I get punished for the sin
he commits.
But didn't you think no a man cannot
because if someone if I did not teach or
influence anyone to sin and he commits a
sin on his own without me even knowing
anything then how am I supposed to pay
for that okay but that wasn't the point
the point was you said another man
cannot bear the sins of someone else you
just changed your position you said no
no no if I teach him to sin and he sins
now he committed the sin he cannot die
for sin Let me finish your point. Hey
brother, why don't you do this man?
Let's get I teach him again. Mhm. Now he
goes and he starts getting every time he
gets because I taught him I will get
punished for every time he got because I
taught it to him. So that means I am
suffering because of someone else's
sins.
Okay. Anyway,